foreign
[Music]
jockle's showing some real uh real
promise
actually no rewind this is this is um
it's like a stock investment segment
yeah put on Creative oh I like that yeah
yeah
you know Adam showing a lot of positive
momentum if I would say I like them I
like the stock you would say I'd say
it's a big buy from me yeah invest your
likes in Adam your life's savings is
what he meant to say yeah yeah like
because this boy is going to the Moon
it wasn't it great when Mr Beast was
like yeah yeah
sorry I had to end it with one of these
bro he got them shorts like diaper tight
dude he has a fupa on his dick
what that doesn't look like a fupa
he's got a dupa a de fupa yeah
I think it's smart you got a big [__]
you got a big dong in there yeah I mean
you know yeah yeah he's harboring
something down there I mean or not with
that confidence
you can't have that like just ignorant
confidence
without having a big old dongle or it's
the inverse you might have a small ass
dick and you go I got nothing to lose
gang yeah yeah it doesn't matter the
worst she can say is ill yeah I say the
same thing yeah that's true but then I
feel like you'd be trying more he
doesn't even try he's just like yeah
naturally just like uh confident so
tonight's dish is going to be fettuccine
Bolognese this is my absolute favorite
Italian Dish I love it I'm particular
about it so I'm gonna try this new
recipe it's from the modern proper it's
all about simplicity so I'm looking for
a dish that's easy to make but it's
going to be delicious so let's go that
[__] is Ace that is Ace can I say
something what that was that was a 28
second monologue
no cuts
that's what I'm saying that that I think
is the definition of talent yeah yep yep
I think that's the thing that people are
magnetized to how can a guy seemingly
sew regular
also be just so put together yeah you
know how many cuts the rest of people
his age require yeah and they're they're
not even half as genuine that's a good
point and I was like that that is
actually a really good point it's it's
pretty rare that you see a 30-second
uncut monologue that was it that was
just and like uh like uh you know like
full body shot too pretty much yeah
that's yeah that's being bold saw from
down here it's not from here it's just
set up the camera full body shot takes
four steps back yep and he's like no
teleprompter just gonna give it to you
how it is Adam jockley here I'm gonna
start a new little segment here almost
like my own little Food Network show uh
it's gonna be cooking with Adam and
today like yeah yeah everyone's like God
damn Alfredo I'm very particular about
it I also I'm harboring a huge dong by
the way you know now you don't have to
say it yeah
he shows it he just shows it yeah he
shows it
so I laid out all the ingredients for
like all the ingredients for my cheating
Bolognese just passes over a horse's
head
the comments are just like looks so good
yeah love you Adam did you cut off so in
love with you yeah I'm so in love with
you just not a single one like are
people not noticing that there's ground
beef ground pork I'm trying out this
carpet marinara sauce he knows what he's
doing with that
full version of The Colony
okay so the first thing you want to do
after you heat up the pan with the olive
oil if you want to saute the vegetables
uh chop up the celery chop up the onions
tossing the carrots so I'm personally
using less carrots and celery than a
recipe calls for just a personal
preference don't be afraid the
experiment and try things out also I'm
going to start heating up the water for
my pasta
okay
right there
let's go
that's a little that's a little o face
yeah I like that weird jaw thing you do
yeah yeah you treat me around I might do
it more
that's what I'm saying you might maybe
make me do it all night yeah
carbon
damn we could Carbone later
they pick you up in my car
Adam if you're saying this Cody's just
jealousy can't be you I'm not jealous I
actually genuinely love his videos yeah
no no I know I know
[Music]
80 10 beef and then 10 horse meat or
he's just doing this in the horror oh
dude and the horse head is just like
spinning in it and he's just
mixing it around
first thing I like to do is just kind of
sous-vide the beef a little bit my
potion yeah it's a it's a pseudo suvi
stirring up my passion here
pseudo suvi just to get the beef good
you want to get a nice Browning on the
meat so apologize in advance for not
having
level cinematography I'm improvising
Adam stop it
you see the jaw hinge at the end of that
one no no no run it back run a pack
provides inside doing the best I can
right now oh
oh it's that [__] it's serving man I
love it I love it he knows what he's
doing with that frame yeah
he knows he's doing with that frame
oh yeah usually you like that [__] yeah
like the way I [__]
[Laughter]
and the the humbleness too yeah right
after like sort of the self-aware like
Sorry Sorry by the way I we're not
making fun of him we are no we're not
I mean this is by definition making fun
but it's oh it's a light teasing okay
that's fine I'm fine with that yeah I'm
not trying to bully him no because I
genuinely enjoy his content I go to his
profile like every day now this is your
Market he was my tick tocker of the week
on this show
he's my tick tocker of the year
I keep tabs on I give like little
personal Awards yeah you're like this is
wards
yeah I'm struggling to think of any o
words
yeah I had this beautiful beautiful
Italian woman over last night made her
orgasm
after she ate some of my carbon yeah
or Gaza orgasm
this is that is this a Maryland accent
I don't know
the jockle accent yeah he's he's like a
um it's the voice you picture you have
like a super in my mind some like super
rich Upstate person yeah
yeah but I just think that the
like you know how like the
the Philly thing is water or whatever
yeah I feel like it's that sort of thing
like that uh Maryland yeah maybe you're
gonna get a lot of Grease so I'm not
gonna show it but I'm definitely gonna
be draining the meat along the way so
let's go training the meat oh draining
the meat
he knows what he's doing he's for
everyone yeah yeah I take it back man
you want to take a peek of the meat yeah
you do
okay so I got a good brownie on my meat
so now I'm going to toss in the whole
jar of the Panera sauce you got a good
Browning on my meat yeah
oh yeah yeah
never use this before so we'll see how
it goes and then we're gonna mix it in
so then I'm gonna throw I don't know how
exciting this is for the audio listeners
but
maybe we should get off this yeah that's
fine